michael and kristen what was your
reaction when you found out that lana
and lex were going to become i never
understood that um i think lana was
trying to protect floyd question just
for us
clark
what are you doing here come on lex you
didn't think i was gonna miss this did
you
tom and michael thank you so much for
joining us i cannot believe we are
celebrating the 20th anniversary of
smallville it is just blowing my mind to
say that but i am very curious to know
what do each of you remember the most
from filming the pilot it's like a blur
i you know there's a moment in this in
the in the pilot where clark trips and
drops his books in front of lana
[Music]
[Applause]
so what are you
man or superman
i haven't figured it out yet i remember
doing it the first time and kind of like
just being like okay that didn't work
whatever and i remember doing saying
that one third time whatever it was
there was one time i did i looked up to
lana and i remember kristen i just saw
you being like
okay yeah that was that was horrible
because you know from a lot of
perspective and i remember i remember
being like not even knowing at the time
being like okay that was the one like it
was so ridiculous because that's what
should have happened yeah i do remember
that and giving you uh mouth-to-mouth
i couldn't stop laughing and thank god
his breath was minty fresh michael likes
a minty fresh breath he's obsessed i'm
obsessed with good breath i think good
breath is very important but i remember
the pilot and i was excited to be there
and also you know i was very new to
shaving my head so i hadn't seen what my
head looks like besides when we shot
that fight no one has been more weird
about he has a beautiful head shaving
head there's nothing wrong with it it
actually he looks better
to be honest
yeah i do you do i need more character
well i was like sluther if i kept my
head shaved i'd be lex luthor always
what
you still say it the same way
astonishment
mixed with a hint of dread yet
for the hopeful finish
michael over the years lex did quite a
few terrible things to
a lot of people on smallville what
stands out the most to you when you look
back at lex's debauchery i i think that
you know there wasn't even enough of
like being bad being villainous and
taking chances and like losing is cool
and i think the biggest moment that i
really enjoy you know that was your
question
was when i pushed lionel luther my
father
out of a 50-story building and that's
how i killed my father no one will even
remember your name
[Music]
did carter know you did that i don't
think i think clark did know or he
assumed that i did it because who else
would do that but um you know there were
some pretty magical moments that you
know
i got to
see but he also made lana think that she
was pregnant
which was
really really manipulative yeah really
bad but kristin and tom one of my
all-time favorite episodes is in season
six when lana finally finds out clark's
true identity i'm from another planet
it's called krypton
it's light years away and my parents
sent me here
to save me
what was your guys's reaction do you
remember to that script and realizing
that it took six years for that moment
to finally happen i don't remember the
script but i remember shooting that
scene that scene was really fun to it
was like a lovely lovely way to to have
her find out it was refreshing to just
open up and share
to someone who you know only has my
character's best interest in mind in
movies or television people getting
together and people breaking up is
interesting people being happy is not
interesting to watch
you know but this is a situation where
two characters who for all those years
like it's very easy to say why didn't he
just tell her in the pilot you know what
i mean
but nobody would have watched that show
right so well and then on the flip side
michael and kristen what was your
reaction when you found out that lana
and lex were going to become i never
understood that um i never understood a
lot of like saying i i think lana was
trying to protect questions
i think kristen was probably like oh god
and then i was probably like yeah
cool
um no i think you know it's funny
because uh chris and i as actors as
friends we got closer as the series sort
of like ended but i think i speak for
you too that we actually
we actually had a lot of fun working
together we worked really well together
and we were just together we worked
really well together as a team and i
liked it i thought it was odd um but i
was like yeah because i thought no way
lana would never be with lex and then i
was like no christopher with michael
with less
that's okay
i thought it might have frightened you
off
you'll have to come up with better scare
tactics
i thought it was really interesting i
mean it was the most fun i had on the
show probably that season it was so
complex
and twisted
and at first i think it was just a like
lex had built trust with lana he had
spent years here's a
coffee shop for you to run like
supported her when she wanted to go to
paris he was kind of this
constant support for her when she didn't
have that consistency from anyone else
and i loved how the relationship just
was them kind of manipulating each other
and
you know kind of hiding things and her
using him and him screwing with her
brain like it was a dark complicated
thing and we hadn't done that on the
show
you aren't capable of love wax
and then it all eventually kind of led
us to the episode that broke my heart in
season eight episode 14 requiem
when lex created two kryptonite bombs
that lana then had to absorb and thus
ended her relationship with clark
wow michael i did that you did you
didn't read the script though because
you weren't there oh yeah i don't know
if i yes i do recall that happening and
you know there was you told me something
about acting is you don't read since
you're not in because you
you know you shouldn't know but lex got
bad i mean he did but
inevitably he did do some things that he
you know he was pushed into a corner and
he tried to do good for so long
and he you know he did some things that
i'm i'm not i wouldn't have done the the
thing for me is i i remember
filming this human kristin clark is also
like you're going to go away from now
you know what i mean like it was like
i'll see you soon and we never got to
see lana again when i and i and i wish
we would have somehow yeah you know then
we kind of transitioned into the lowest
metropolis thing and whatnot but i did
feel like when lana was going away in
that scene i it wasn't like bye i'll
never see you again he's like i'll see
you soon we just got to figure this out
and that's the hope that's what
smallmouth was always about
we're in each other's hearts clark
i will always be with you
so kristin how did you feel about that
having that be lana's exit and would you
change anything if you could
i don't know i mean i i liked that she
got to go off and do her own thing that
she got to kind of self-actualize
it was kind of a good ending for her
that way and i think her dependent all
of her time on smallville was so wrapped
up in all of these guys i think that it
gave her a chance to just go live her
life even though you never see it she
gets people who loved her get to imagine
whatever whatever life she got to live
that was separate from the mayhem and
chaos
of uh of her life in smallville tom
since you played clark kent there have
been so many super men on tv and movies
like let's be real you were such a trend
setter but whenever you have cross paths
with brandon ralph or henry cavill or
tyler hoakland what has that been like
for you and what do you guys bond over i
have i have not met henry but i've met
the other guys and it's just fun it's
just
high fives what's up it's just it's
awesome i mean everybody's trying to do
the best they can there's no you'd think
there would be competition there's
actually zero and maybe that's something
about playing clark kent you know i bet
if a bunch of lexus met together they'd
probably get it i'd be like jessie
what are you doing man yeah what's up
jack dog i couldn't say that but yeah
it's it's been awesome it's been awesome
well my last question for you guys is
there have been rumors swirling around
about some kind of a smallville
continuation a movie an animated series
where we could see you guys lend your
voices is that a possibility what can
you tell me all i could say is that tom
and i are working on something with the
creators of smallville and we're going
to hopefully approach warner brothers
relatively soon and that's all i could
say and uh we're just working hard on it
and we hope that they uh they like what
we're
thinking kristen would you be interested
in whatever this cryptic thing is
theoretically yes yeah we'll take care
of it
yeah you'll like it yeah it'll be great
all right how about this you guys come
back to eg and then you tell us the
exclusive when it's ready
[Music]